name's maximum Barty and I've been an
agent for ten goddamn years you want to
know what it's like let me tell you
about the Lombardi tails
[Music]
[ __ ] mother [ __ ] open fire open fire
[ __ ] still common don't shoot it in the
head
Gomora [ __ ] shoot the legs shoot the
[ __ ] mic [ __ ] get the platform back
you sons of [ __ ] okay you got some
breathing space let's see the damage the
more you're gonna be okay I see Morse
just lie back a few will see to you all
right I'll get down you [ __ ] sir
orgeous sir boys secure the perimeter me
and the captain need to have a chat sir
you gonna be okay now excuse me with all
due respect sir you are gonna be okay
because my boys are counting on you to
get us out of this so what do you got
damn orders
okay get things secured I'm gonna do
that you just get your head right okay
first I'm gonna bug hunt like this you
bound to get a little freaked it's okay
Jones I'm Audi report backup power is
gonna last at least another hour plenty
of time
don't worry we got this ain't we the
baddest [ __ ] in the land keep
your eyes sharp heads down and we'll
make it out okay
Jackson how's Kimora
okay just stick with him long as
possible
we'll keep you covered don't leave him
alone until well you should not be alone
right now
Zimmer keep working on comms we gotta
figure out what the [ __ ] the rest of
this site's up to see if they're working
on power or if we're on our own all
right captain how you doing look but you
think the [ __ ] was gonna be easy I'm
gonna be frank with you this is what the
real world is like this is what me and
my boys deal with you want a combat
experience this is it you maybe just
thought you keep your head down get
enough to get promoted but that just
ain't gonna happen you're in this unit
you get in the blender just like the
rest of us so here's the situation
we ain't seeing the insurgents since the
first attack before it lots of gunfire
though so whatever they're after they
ain't got it yet I think they're on this
level but I can't be sure until they
make contact the ugly [ __ ] still
trying to get through the blast doors I
don't think it'll manage for a while
even when the auxiliary power goes out
completely the blast doors will be shut
however I don't want to count on it
being stopped cold more if it can't go
through this way it's gonna go somewhere
else
maybe get away
the jewelry power is going to go down in
about 45 minutes and we'll have even
more breaches we need to get power back
online and keep it attention so it
doesn't try to get off site once we got
power the automatic system should let us
trap it pretty easy until help arrives
so what are your orders then sir we
can't set off the [ __ ] nuke that's
the last [ __ ] resort even if we get a
major breach we ain't the only assets in
the area
sike 34th no sir we haven't been able to
contact them but that's because we're on
the ground and the comm systems out yes
I'm sure they're yes sir yes I
understand I'll give the orders Jones
your squads going with the captain you
got to get into the shelter take them
through the tunnels it'll take longer
but the [ __ ] can't fit through there
so you should be safer keep your heads
down though we got insurgents running
around god only knows what the [ __ ] else
they let out of their cages
the rest of you going to move down Hall
42 make a ruckus get fugly attention be
ready to shut the blast doors as soon as
it gets close bonds you're with me yes
captain no sir I ain't going with you
I'm gonna go make one more try to fix
the power and then I won't get into the
[ __ ] shelter until every last one of
my boys is there yes sir I see I still
ain't going don't give that order we'll
both regret it
thank you sir
I'll have power back up by the time you
get to the shelter I don't then you can
think about setting off the nuke so
after that me and Barnes we went to get
the power sir none it was a long shot
but the captain wasn't gonna wait for my
voice I was going to give him the best
chance possible yes sir I know my places
with my men especially when I command an
officer out but I'm an engineer I was
the only wanting to get the power run
like I said the best chance they had
Barnes was with me every step well
almost every step yeah I did leave him
but it was for 10 50 minutes tops
I think it some breakers reset and I
needed him watching the doors anyway it
took us some time but we got the power
back on once we did we were able to get
out early contained pretty easy and the
reinforcements from sight 34 cleaned up
the insurgents Jones told me he was
ordered by the captain the covers
retreat down the tunnels after he got
pinned down by insurgents
we found the captain dead in the shelter
never got to the button doesn't look
like
no sir I didn't know the shelter's
cameras were working let me pick up tall
[ __ ] in a trench coat
sounds like nobody don't know what the
[ __ ] he was doing there
I'll talk to security get a rundown of
everything missing no sir I don't know I
got through all of us I'll talk to the
boys see if anyone saw anything take it
from me though now that they didn't you
know see nobody unless he wants you to
see him it's almost like he was trying
to make a point of something
[Music]